défi football mais aussi tir à l'arc et
trapèze pour la troisième édition des
olympiades de la ville montigny le
bretonneux proposait de nombreuses
activités et huit structures gonflables
et des parcours d'obstacles de 30 mètres
et est installée au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin un défi avant tout
amicale entre les huit quartiers de la
ville c'est participer couverte à nous
le disait participer aux sports et
découvrir aussi s'initier et découvrir
c'est très important parce que le sport
aujourd'hui fait partie de la vie on se
doit tout on se doit on peut tous
pratiqué à une activité sportive alors
arrivés sur place les inimités ont reçu
un bracelet à la couleur de leur
quartier et une carte chaque
participation à une activité rapporter
un point au quartier et beaucoup se sont
pris au jeu
vac c'est bien pour que les jeunes qui
sort tout ça correspond ferme chez nous
y'a plein de château gonflable pour pour
sauter pour rouler il ya plein de choses
à essayer nouvelle trapèze des mobilités
nouvelle avec à leur bord des autres
très sympa c'est bien pour l'instant
je m'amuse bien et j'espère que je fais
un regard du monde fr dany plutôt en
quartier l'entousiasme de ce jeune
n'aura pas suffi après deux victoires en
deux éditions du village c'est le
quartier de lasours de riz qui a
remporté les olympiades de montigny le
bretonneux